From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It all started at a live fish and meat market in Wuhan, a city in Central China. No one knows exactly how or when, but one day late last year, a coronavirus leaped from an animal into a human. Before long, people all around Wuhan started getting sick. We know what happened next. To curb the spread of this coronavirus, China announced a draconian lockdown of more than 11 million people in Wuhan. No one in, no one out.
来自NPR，这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这一切始于中国中部城市武汉的一个活鱼和肉类市场。没有人确切知道是如何或何时开始的，但在去年年底的某一天，一种冠状病毒从动物跃传给了人类。不久之后，武汉各地的民众开始生病。我们都知道接下来发生了什么。为了遏制这种冠状病毒的传播，中国宣布对武汉超过1100万人口实施严厉的封锁。只进不出。
What we're seeing and hearing on the internet is police and hazmat suits going door to door, taking people away who either have a fever or are rumored to have been in contact with someone who did. Containment is the goal here and using whatever means is necessary. By the time China had set up these containment measures, the virus had slipped outside of Wuhan. It began spreading to other places across the globe. From South Korea, two patients may have contracted the disease
我们在互联网上看到和听到的是，警察和身穿防护服的人挨家挨户带走那些发烧或据传曾与患者接触过的人。这里的目标是遏制疫情，并动用一切必要的手段。就在中国采取这些遏制措施时，病毒已经溜出了武汉。它开始向全球其他地方传播。在韩国，两名患者可能是在当地感染了该疾病，或者是你在排队时站在你旁边的人。再到意大利。该地区政府为保护该地区的14个省份免受疫情影响，采取了只许进不许出的策略。不仅如此，它还成为了该国早期的一个疫情热点。
from someone who was infected here in the nation or whom you are standing by on the line. To Italy. The government's strategy to protect the epidemic for the region's 14-pronged region is to be entered and to be left behind. Not only that, it emerged as an early hotspot for that nation.
在2月下旬，意大利政府开始对伦巴第地区的居民实施旅行限制。但为时已晚。3月8日，随着病毒疯狂蔓延，政府对伦巴第及周边14个省的约1600万人口实施了封锁。从理论上讲，这意味着人们不应该离开这些地区，但实际上当局根本没有时间，甚至可能没有资源将其实际落地。在米兰和其他受封锁影响的地区，人们涌向火车站，
Near the end of February, the Italian government began imposing travel restrictions on residents of the Lombardi region. But it was too late. On March 8, with the virus spreading wildly, the government locked down some 16 million people in Lombardi and 14 neighboring provinces. In theory, it means that people are not supposed to leave those areas, but in fact the authorities simply haven't had the time and perhaps not even the resources to make this a reality. In Milan and in other areas affected by the lockdown, people race to train stations
试图在为时已晚之前离开。许多逃离伦巴第的人将病毒带到了意大利的其他地方。很快，意大利的死亡人数与中国的死亡人数形成了鲜明对比。感觉意大利就像是一个永远无法堵住每天数百人死亡的漏洞。这个拥有600万人口的国家的冠状病毒死亡人数现在已经超过了拥有15亿人口的中国。它使世界上最好的医疗保健系统之一陷入了瘫痪。关于冠状病毒疫情的故事仍在书写中。
trying to get out before it's too late. Many of those people fleeing Lombardi brought the virus with them to other parts of Italy. Very soon, the death toll in Italy versus the death toll in China told its own story. It feels like a whole that Italy just can't plug the daily loss of hundreds of lives. Coronavirus fatalities in this country of 60 million people now higher than in China with a population of one and a half billion. It's brought one of the world's best health care systems to its knees. The story of the coronavirus outbreak is still being written.
我们尚不清楚将从这场大流行中吸取的所有教训。仍有一些细节尚未完全披露，包括中国政府是否透露了疫情的真实规模。话虽如此，我们能从这次疫情以及各国如何应对中吸取哪些早期的教训呢？自从我们能够从这次疫情以及各国如何应对中吸取教训。本周的“隐藏的大脑”节目中，我们将探讨国家和个人如何在危机时刻以及日常交往中看待规则。文化对遵守规则和打破规则的态度在各种方面塑造着我们的生活，从我们家庭的紧密程度到我们的政治偏好，
We don't yet know all the lessons that will be drawn from the pandemic. There are still details that have not been fully divulged, including whether the Chinese government has revealed the true scope of the outbreak. That said, are there early lessons we can draw from the outbreak and how nations have responded? since we can draw from the outbreak and how nations have responded. This week on Hidden Brain, we're going to look at how nations and individuals think about rules, both in moments of crisis and in everyday interactions. Cultural attitudes about rule following and rule breaking shape our lives in all kinds of ways, from the tightness of our homes, to our political preferences,
再到我们制止大流行蔓延的方法。本NPR播客及以下信息的支持来自BetterHelp。由持证专业咨询师提供的在线咨询，专注于隔离、访问、压力和焦虑。访问betterhelp.com斜杠hidden brain了解更多信息并获得第一个月10%的折扣。米歇尔·加尔凡是马里兰大学的心理学家。她研究
to our approaches topping the spread of a pandemic. Support for this NPR podcast and the following message come from BetterHelp. Online counseling by licensed professional counselors, specializing in isolation, depression, stress, and anxiety. Visit betterhelp.com slash hidden brain to learn more and get 10% off your first month. Michelle Galfan is a psychologist at the University of Maryland. She studies how
组织、社区和国家是如何被其文化塑造的。她是《规则制定者，规则打破者》一书的作者。在其他人可能只看到国家之间及其应对大流行政策差异的地方，米歇尔·加尔凡看到了文化的隐形之手。它塑造着选择、决定和结果。米歇尔·加尔凡，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。很高兴来到这里。你的很多工作都涉及关注那些熟悉的事物，
organizations, communities and nations are shaped by their cultures. She's the author of the book, Rulemakers, Rulebreakers. Where others might see only policy differences between nations and how they respond to a pandemic, Michelle Galfan sees the hidden hand of culture. It shapes choices, decisions, and outcomes. Michelle Galfan, welcome to Hidden Brain. Great to be here. A lot of your work involves paying attention to things that are familiar
并用崭新的眼光看待它们。我想看几个这样的例子。你在书的早期谈到过，一个柏林的行人在夜里11点站在交通路口。里面一辆车也没有。她过马路吗？灯变绿时她过马路，但即使四周没有车，她也原封不动地待在原地。当然，在远隔大西洋的波士顿，我们并没有看到同样的事情发生，尽管这是红灯，而且可能有一个标牌写着禁止通行。没错。在波士顿，在我的原籍纽约，你会看到行人肆无忌惮地横穿
and seeing them with fresh eyes. I want to look at a few of these examples. You talk early in the book about a pedestrian in Berlin standing at a traffic intersection at 11 o'clock in the night. There isn't a car inside. Does she cross the road? She crosses the road when the light turns green, but stays put even if there's no cars around. And of course, a continent away in Boston, we don't see the same thing happening even though it's Russia and there might be a sign saying don't walk. That's right. In Boston, in New York, my hometown originally, you see J. Walker's incessantly crossing
马路，甚至还带着孩子。当然，我们所有人都见过这一点，当我们去过不同的城市和不同的国家时，我们会注意到人们的行为方式有所不同。有趣的是，我们实际上并没有停下来惊叹这些差异在各地是多么的一致。没错。这确实是一个谜，因为文化无处不在。它就在我们身边，但却是隐形的。我们真的把它当作理所当然，尽管它从早到晚都在塑造我们的行为。通常只有当你跳出自己的文化时，你才会意识到自己
the street even with kids in tow. And of course, all of us have seen this, as we've gone to different cities and different countries, we sort of noticed that people behave differently. The interesting thing is that we don't actually stop to marvel at how consistent those differences are across places. That's right. It's really a puzzle because culture is omnipresent. It's all around us, but it's invisible. We really take it for granted, even though it's shaping our behavior from morning until night. And often it's only the case when you get outside of your culture that you realize you've
已经被你自己的社会化以及遵守规范或打破规范深深地塑造了。是的，有个关于鱼和水的古老笑话，不是吗？没错。两条鱼在游来游去，然后它们经过另一条鱼，那条鱼对它们说，嘿，伙计们，水怎么样？它们继续游着，其中一条转向另一条说，到底什么是水？这真的很有趣，因为这说明了一个深刻的观点，有时我们周围最重要的现实是我们没有真正看到的。对于鱼来说，那是水，但对人类来说，那是文化。所以你在书里有很多例子都在谈论这个。据我所知，瑞士银行UBS有一份写下来的着装规范。
been so profoundly shaped by your own socialization and norm-boggling or norm-breaking. Yeah, there's the old joke about the fish and the water, isn't it? That's right. Two fish are swimming around, and then they pass by another fish who says to them, hey boys, how's the water? And they swim on and one turns the other and says, what the heck is water? And it's really funny because this illustrates a profound point, which is that sometimes it's the most important realities around us that we don't really see. And for fish, that's water, but for humans, that's culture. So you have lots of examples of the book that talk about this. I understand the Swiss Bank UBS has a dress code that's actually written down.
没错。多年来一直如此，大约有30多页的着装规范。你可以看到，规则的严格程度在这么多不同的地方都能找到。例如，在新加坡，你不被允许带入大量的口香糖。对于这样做的人，他们可能会受到相当严重的罚款，包括乱扔垃圾或在街上吐痰等事情。这些事情在新加坡会受到严厉的惩罚。事实上，即使你赤身裸体在家里走动，窗帘拉着但窗户开着，这也可能在新加坡为你带来巨额罚款。它被称为罚款之国，因为它以对看似轻微的违法行为进行大量惩罚而闻名。
That's right. It had been for many years, like 30 somewhat pages of dress codes. And you can see that the strictness of rules is found in so many different places. In Singapore, for example, you're not allowed to bring in large quantities of gum. And for people who do that, they can get fined pretty seriously, including things like littering or spitting on the street. These things can be strictly punished in Singapore. In fact, even if you're walking around your house naked in front of the curtains with them open, this can get you a hefty fine in Singapore. It's called the fine nation because it's known for having a lot of punishments for seemingly minor offenses.
我猜这些规则在圣保罗不会那么受欢迎。没错。我们可以看到，你知道，在巴西和新西兰这样地方有更多的宽容度。而在某种程度上，在美国，你会发现每天都有一连串违反规范的行为，无论是在新西兰人们赤脚在银行走红，用数千个胸罩装饰栅栏，在大学校园里烧沙发，还是上班超级迟到。这太惊人了。世界各地在制定规则的人或打破规则的人方面存在着各种差异
I'm guessing that these rules wouldn't go down so well in Sao Paulo. That's right. We could see that, you know, there's much more permissiveness in places like Brazil and New Zealand. And the United States, to some extent, where you find a slew of norm violations every day, whether it's people walking barefoot in banks in New Zealand and decorating their fences with thousands of bras and burning couches on university campuses or showing up to work really super late. It's astonishing. The sort of differences around the world in terms of people who are making the rules or breaking
我喜欢你在书中举的例子，巴西人实际上有一个短语，用来形容他们计划准时开会时的情况。他们称之为“英国式准时”。没错。这真的是像英国人那样严格遵守规则。当他们想确保人们准时时，他们必须提醒自己，他们
them. I love the example you've given the book that Brazilians actually have a phrase for when they plan to be on time for a meeting. They call it Compontualidade Britannica. That's right. That's really follow the rules like they do in Britain. When they want to make sure that people are on time, they have to remind themselves that they
有他们自己的文化，他们自己基本上不围绕时间制定太多规则的规范。所以当你跨文化工作时，很显然，你会发现这相当令人沮丧，因为人们在诸如时间、组织程度、同步程度以及对看似轻微的事情给予多少惩罚等基本问题上存在差异。你知道，我记得多年前访问里约热内卢时，我在马拉卡纳体育场观看了一场足球比赛，
have their own culture, their own norms of basically not really having a whole lot of rules around time. So when you're working, obviously, across cultures, you can see this would be pretty frustrating where people have differences in their Their rules are around basic things like time and and how organized they are how synchronized they are how many How much punishment they give for even seemingly minor things? You know, I remember visiting a Rio de Janeiro many years ago and I attended a soccer match at Murakana Stadium
我们都坐在那些塑料座位上。有一刻，坐在我旁边的一位球迷对一个犯了错误的球员非常不满。于是他站起来说，对着那个球员大喊大叫。他称他为，我该怎么说呢？他称那个球员是一个性工作者的私生子。我这么说吧。然后他踢了他前面的塑料座位，以至于座位飞过了后面三排球迷的头顶。
And they were these plastic seats that we were all sitting on. And at one point the fans sitting next to me was very upset with the player who had made a mistake. And so he got up and said, it's screaming at this player. And he called him, how shall I put this? He called the player the illegitimate child of a sex worker. Let me just put it that way. And then he kicked the plastic seat in front of him so that it flew over the heads of the fans
让我惊讶的不仅是他做了这件事，而且绝对没有人注意到他。是的，这很有趣。有关于访问巴西的人的故事，包括世界杯期间的日本球员和球迷，他们有非常不同类型的行为。如果你来自日本或塞内加尔，显然你会尽自己的一份力清理自己的垃圾。
in the next three rows. And what was amazing to me was not just that he did this, but that absolutely no one paid him any attention. Yeah, it's interesting. There's stories of people who are visiting Brazil, including Japanese players and fans during the World Cup that had very different types of behaviors. If you're from Japan or a Senegal, apparently you do your part to clean up your mess.
什么？是的。世界杯结束后，日本人正在清理体育场。看到日本人在这些巴西人的情境中表现出这种有组织的行动，人们感到十分震惊，因为在这些情境中，你会看到大量无序的行为，而人们甚至都没有注意到，因为它太典型了。我们对群体之间的这些差异非常熟悉，以至于我们有围绕这些主题构建的电影和电视节目。这些差异也出现在我们的家庭生活和工作场所中。
What? Yeah. After the World Cup, the Japanese were cleaning up the stadium. And it was astonishing to people to see this kind of organized action among Japanese in these Brazilian contexts where you see a whole host of disorderly behavior that people don't even notice because it's so typical. We are so familiar with these differences between groups that we have movies and television shows that are built around these themes. These differences also show up in our domestic lives and in workplaces.
你可以从许多不同的角度思考我们的严格或宽容程度，从国家的角度、组织的角度，或者我们自己的家庭。在书中我谈到我们都有自己想成为哪种布偶的偏好。有些人是秩序布偶，想想科克蛙。我今天来到这里是为了向你们提供。他们真的很喜欢规则，他们管理自己的冲动，并且非常喜欢大量的秩序和结构。
You can think about how strict or permissive we are from many different perspectives, from national perspective, from organizations, anywhere on our own households. In the book I talk about how we all have our own preference for the kind of muppet we want to be. Some people are order muppets, things about Kermit the Frog. And I am here today to offer to you. They really like rules, they manage their impulses, and they really like a lot of order and structure.
而在另一面，有些人是混乱布偶。我喜欢烹饪。我觉得这里的烹饪更好。他们往往不太注意规则。他们更倾向于冒险和冲动，并且对混乱更加宽容。这在人与人之间引起了很大的冲突。想想那些试图抚养孩子的父母，他们在应该有多严格的观念上存在分歧，或者在财务上，甚至在如何装洗碗机这方面，我发现在我的家庭里也会遭到一些批评。所以我觉得
And then a flip side, some people are casemuffins. I love cooking. I think cooking is better here. They tend to not really notice rules. They are more risk-taking and impulsive and they're more tolerant about beauty. Causes a lot of conflict between people. Think about parents who are trying to raise kids and they have different ideas in terms of how strict they should be or finances or even how you load the dishwasher I found in my household can get you a little flack. So I think it's
真正把这看作是影响我们所有时间的文化的一个方面是很重要的，从我们的国家到我们的家庭。我不得不问你关于洗碗机的事，你家里的冲突是什么？嗯，我倾向于更随性。我的丈夫是一名律师，出于充分的理由，他倾向于更严格。他从事的职业有很多问责制、许多标准和监督，而我往往倾向于更随性的一方。因此，当我装洗碗机时，他发现这简直令人难以置信地不安，因为我并没有真正注意它是多么有组织。或者如果我在床上叠毛巾，我会得到一些反馈。
important to really look at this as a aspect of culture that affects us all the time from our nations to our households. I have to ask you about the dishwasher what's the conflict in your household? Well, I tend to lean looser. My husband, who's a lawyer, leans tighter for good reasons. He's an occupation where there's a lot of accountability, a lot of standards and monitoring, and I tend to be a little bit on the looser side. And so he finds it really unbelievably disturbing when I load the dishwasher because I don't really pay attention to how organized it is. Or if I weave towels on the bed, I get a little bit of feedback.
我们通过尝试思考哪些领域我们需要收紧，哪些领域我们可以更随性，来真正尝试谈判解决这些差异。我们甚至和孩子们谈论这件事，我们试图思考我们的优先事项是什么。当我们试图根据家里的规则强度进行组织时，对我们每个人来说真正重要的是什么。正如你所指出的，可能有些领域
We've come to really try to negotiate these differences by trying to think about what domains do we need to be tightened and what domains can we be looser in. And we even talk about it with the kids, and we try to think about what's our priorities. What's really important to each of us as we try to organize on the strength of rules in the house. Because as you point out, there might be domains
实际上拥有相当随意的规则是完全没问题的，而另一些领域拥有随意的规则实际上是灾难性的。是的，这正是重点。所以在我们家里，为了让你对谈判及其进展有一个概念，我们最终确实同意，某些领域比如我们的健康以及孩子们在学校努力学习的工作量，严格要求是非常重要的。但其他事情，比如你的就寝时间或者你有多乱，这是一场艰难的谈判，因为家里
where actually it's perfectly fine to have fairly lack of daisicle rules, and other domains where it's actually catastrophic to have lack of daisicle rules. Yeah, that's exactly the point. So in our house, just to give you a sense of the negotiation and how it played out, we finally did agree that some domains like our health and how much we work in terms of studying hard for the kids for school are really important to be strict about. But other things like your bedtime or how messy you are, that was a tough negotiation because the house is
有点乱，让托德抓狂。但这些是可以更随性的领域。我们必须给一些领域留出空间，让人们有自由去做他们想做的事，但我们需要知道哪些是需要更严格的优先领域。特别是在像美国这样一个建立在自由理念之上的国家，规则可能看起来很繁琐。为什么我们不能挑选最适合我们的规则呢？米歇尔说，我们可能不喜欢规则，
kind of a mess and drives Todd crazy. But those are domains that could be much looser. We have to give some domains where people can have freedom to just do what they want, but we need to know which of the priority domains to be more strict in. Especially in a country like the United States, which is built around the idea of freedom. Rules can seem onerous. Why can't we just pick and choose the rules that work best for us? Michelle says we might not like rules,
但我们可能更不喜欢一个没有规则的国家。想象一个没有任何规则的世界。他们只是做一个思想实验，你走到外面，人们在他们觉得合适的任何一侧路上开车，他们无视交通信号灯，或者想想去你最喜欢的餐厅，人们张着大嘴咀嚼，他们从所有人的盘子里偷食物。
but we would probably like a country with no rules, even less. Imagine a world without any kind of rules. They just do a thought experiment where you go outside and people are driving on whatever side of the road they feel like and they're ignoring traffic lights or think about going to your favorite restaurant and people are chewing with their mouths wide open and they're stealing food of all people's plates.
这实际上听起来像是我的纽约家庭。或者想象你登上一个拥挤的电梯，发现人们面向后方，到处挥舞着他们的雨伞。我鼓励听众看看如果你这样做会发生什么。你得到了什么样的反应？或者想象一个世界，人们在公共汽车、飞机和电影院里到处发生性行为。这是一个没有社会规则或任何商定的行为标准的社会，幸运的是我们发明了这些类型的规则来避免这些情况。在某种程度上，你可以认为，如果没有这些规则，社会将无法运转，
That sounds like my New York family actually. Or imagine that you board a crowded elevator and you find people facing backwards and shaking their umbrellas all over the place. I encourage the listeners to see what happens if you do something of that. What kind of responses do you get? Or imagine a world where people are having sex all over the place on buses, airplanes, and movie theaters. This is a world without social norms or any agreed upon standards for behavior, and luckily we have invented these kinds of rules to avoid these scenarios. In a way you can think about it as societies with cease to function without these kinds
它们是将我们凝聚在一起的粘合剂。米歇尔谈论的不仅是我们拥有的规则，还有我们关于遵守规则的规则。我们对秩序和结构的偏好是一丝不苟吗？还是我们更喜欢有回旋余地？当我们回来时，我们将深入探讨米歇尔用来理解这些偏好的框架。真正做出补偿需要什么？我们应该如何驾驭我们的数字空间？我是安努
of rules that the glue that bind us together. What Michelle is talking about is not just the rules we have, but the rules we have about following the rules. Are we exacting about our preferences for order and structure? Or do we prefer to have wiggle room? When we come back, we dig into Michelle's framework for understanding these preferences. What does it take to really make amends? And how should we navigate our digital spaces? I'm Anou
萨莫罗迪。每周在NPR的“泰德TED演讲”节目中，我们都会与TED演讲者一起踏上一段旅程，他们帮助我们回答一些人生中的重大问题。加入我们。立即收听。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我正在与马里兰大学的跨文化心理学家米歇尔·加尔凡交谈。米歇尔，你在书中用了相当多的篇幅谈到像日本或新西兰这样在多么关心遵守规则方面截然不同的国家。你还暗示，在某种程度上，这些国家的历史在
Summerodi. Each week on NPR's Ted Radio Hour we go on a journey with Ted speakers who help us answer some of life's biggest questions. Join us. Listen now. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm speaking with cross-cultural psychologists Michelle Galfan at the University of Maryland. Michelle, you talk at some length in the book about countries like Japan or New Zealand that are very different in terms of how much they care about following the rules. You also suggest in some ways that the history of these countries plays some role
人们如何看待规则方面发挥了一定作用。你是什么意思？是的，你知道，我认为认识到文化出于正当理由而演变是很重要的。如果你看看像日本这样的地方，你可以看到它们在历史上一直面临着长期的威胁。我的意思是，想想大自然的愤怒，日本几个世纪以来一直面临的持续自然灾害和饥荒。或者他们曾在自己的国土上多次卷入潜在冲突，
in how people come to think about the rules. What do you mean by that? Yeah, you know, I think that it's important to recognize that culture evolves for good reasons. And if you look at places like Japan, you can see that they've been faced with chronic threat in their histories. I mean, think about Mother Nature's fury, the constant natural disasters,
将其与新西兰进行对比，在新西兰的领土上，几乎没有什么这种威胁的历史。因此，他们在历史进程中形成了非常不同的心态，这或许并不令人惊讶，我们需要了解这些生态和历史因素，才能真正理解文化差异？所以你会把像日本这样的国家称为文化紧密型国家，而把新西兰称为文化松散型国家。
and famine that has been faced by the Japanese for centuries. Or how many times they've been potentially involved in conflict on their own soil, contrast that with New Zealand, where there's been very little history of these kinds of threats on New Zealand's territory. So it may not be that surprising that they develop very different mindsets over the course of their histories, and we need to understand those ecological and historical factors to really make sense of cultural differences? So you would call a country like Japan culturally tight and a country like New Zealand culturally
米歇尔，这些术语是什么意思？所以我前面提到过所有群体都有社会规范，这些商定的行为标准。我们基本上需要这些规范来协调和预测彼此的行为。它们是将我们凝聚在一起的粘合剂。但我发现的是，这种粘合剂在某些情境下比其他情境下更强。
lose. What do you mean by those terms, Misha? So I mentioned earlier that all groups have social norms, these agreed upon standards of behavior. And we needed these norms to basically coordinate and predict each other's behaviors. They're the glue that bind us together. But what I've discovered is that that glue is stronger in some context than others.
有些文化是紧密的，我的意思是它们有严格的规范和对偏离这些规范的人的惩罚。而其他群体是松散的。它们的规范较弱，并且宽容得多。我们可以思考这种术语，紧密和松散，这可以帮助我们理解国家、州、组织甚至我们自己的家庭。因此，紧密和松散并非关于你是否有规则，而是真正关于你遵循规则的程度、你在乎规则的程度、规则对你有多重要。紧密型文化有很多规则，并且对这些规则的执行非常严格。
Some cultures are tight by which I mean that they have strict norms and punishments for people that are deviating from those norms. And other groups are loose. They have weaker norms and they're much more permissive. And it's something that we can think about this terminology, tight and loose that can help us understand nations and states and organizations and even our own households. And so tightness and looseness is not about whether you have rules, but it's really about how much you follow the rules, how much you care about the rules, how important the rules are to you. Tight cultures have a lot of rules, and they're very strict about the enforcement of those
松散型文化拥有更少、实际上更加模糊的规则，并且宽容得多。即使在相同的情况下，它们也允许更广泛的行为范围，想想图书馆，我们中的许多人一进入图书馆就知道这是一个紧密的情境。你不会开始唱歌跳舞，也不会开始大声播放收音机。
rules. Loose cultures have fewer rules that are actually much more ambiguous, and they're much more permissive. They afford a wider range of behavior as permissible, even in the same situation, think about a library, which many of us, as soon as we get into libraries, we know this is a tight situation. You're not going to start singing and dancing and start playing your radio really loudly.
在世界各地，图书馆到处都相当严格。但引人注目的是，这也是我们在研究中可以看到的，即使在松散的情境中，与紧密文化中的同类情境相比，人们在图书馆里也会做一些奇怪的事情。或者以城市公园为例，它要松散得多。允许的行为范围更广。我们可以在像巴基斯坦这样的地方看到这一点，
And around the world, libraries are pretty strict everywhere. But what's remarkable, and this is what we can see in research, is that even in loose context, people are doing also to weird things in libraries compared to in tight cultures in the same situation. Or take a city park where it's much looser. There's a wider range of behavior that's permissible. We can see that in places like Pakistan,
是的，在这种情境下允许的行为更多，但它仍然比美国的公共公园更严格。所以我们都有一个规范雷达，思考哪些情境是紧密的，哪些是松散的，我们惊人地度过每一天却从未意识到，我们在这些情境中转变了我们的规范心态。然而，我们在世界各地完全相同的情境（如图书馆、公园、电梯）中看到人们的行为存在广泛的差异。
yeah, there's much more behavior that's permissible in this context, but it's still stricter in public parks than in the United States. So we all have a normative radar thinking about which situations are tight and loose and we amazingly go through our days without ever realizing it, that we're shifting our normative mindsets in these contexts. But nevertheless, we see wide variation in how people act in the same exact situations, libraries, public parks, elevators, even around the world.
所以如果你看一下像日本这样的国家，米歇尔，你在书中辩称，文化紧密性演变的驱动因素之一与威胁的经历和历史威胁有关。在日本的背景下谈谈这一点。是的，所以在我们几年前发表在《科学》杂志上的关于紧密和松散的研究中，我们着手研究我们是否可以衡量世界各地的紧密和松散，认识到所有文化都有紧密和松散的元素，我们想看看我们是否可以根据紧密和松散的连续体对日本、新西兰、希腊和荷兰等国家进行分类。
So if you look at a country like Japan for a second, Michelle, you argue in the book that one of the drivers of the evolution of these tight cultures has to do with the experience of threat and historical threat. Talk about that in the context of Japan. Yes, so in this study that we did on tightness and looseness that was published in science some years ago, we set out to study can we measure tightness and looseness around the world, recognizing that all cultures have tight and loose elements, we wanted to see can we classify countries like Japan and New Zealand and Greece and in Netherlands on a continuum of tightness
这就是我们所做的。我们可以看到我们可以衡量这个结构。然后我们可以说，好吧，为什么会这样，是什么解释了这种变化？我有种直觉，这可能与人们在面对威胁时需要协调其社会行动的程度有关。
and looseness. And that's what we did. We can see that we can measure this construct. And then we can say, well, why is this, what's explaining this variation? And I had a hunch that it might be related to the degree of which people need to coordinate their social action and the face of threat.
现在，并非所有紧密文化都有威胁，并非所有松散文化都缺乏威胁，但在我们的研究中，威胁与紧密性之间似乎存在着非常显著的联系。因此，当我为这项研究收集世界各地的数据时，我正在收集这些国家的生态和历史数据。例如，我收集了早在1500年的人口密度数据，我研究了一个国家在自己的国土上被潜在入侵了多少次。
Now, not all tight cultures have threat, not all of loose cultures lack it, but there seem to be in our research a pretty significant connection between threats and tightness. So as I was collecting data around the world for this study, I was gathering data on the ecologies and the histories of these nations. I got data on population density for example as far back as 1500 and I studied how many times a nation was potentially invaded on their own soil.
而不是他们卷入了世界各地的多少冲突。例如，美国卷入了许多冲突，但除了一些例外，在我们的历史上，我们没有来自墨西哥和加拿大的长期入侵。我们在这项研究中能够证明的是，那些遭受很多威胁的国家往往更紧密，比如日本、德国和奥地利，而像新西兰、希腊和巴西这样遭受较少威胁的国家则往往更松散。在某种程度上，这完全说得通，不是吗？如果你经历过很多艰难时期，你在某种程度上随着时间的推移学到了，
Not how much conflict they've been involved around the world. The U.S. for example has been involved in a lot of conflict, but with some exceptions, we haven't had chronic invasions from Mexico and Canada, for example, across our history. And what we were able to show in this study is that the countries that had a lot of threat tend to be tighter, like Japan and Germany and Austria, as compared to countries like New Zealand and Greece and Brazil that tend to have less threat. And at a certain level that makes perfect sense, isn't it? If you've been through a lot of tough times, you sort of learned in some ways over time
团结在一起是很重要的。没错。我的意思是，这很有道理。当你面临集体威胁时，你无法靠自己解决问题。在这些情况下，你真的需要依靠其他人不叛逃、不以自我为中心、大规模协调以应对威胁以求生存。
that it's important to hang together. That's right. I mean, it makes a lot of sense. When you have collective threat, you can't solve this on your own. You need to really rely on other people in these situations to not defect, to not be egocentric, to coordinate at a scale to deal with the threat for survival.
事实上，我们在一些计算模型中看到了完全相同的逻辑。随着威胁增加，生存。事实上，我们在数学模型中也看到了完全相同的逻辑。随着数学模型中威胁的增加，我们看到群体往往会进化得更加紧密。因此，似乎有某种东西在进化上是有意义的，即在大量威胁下，我们往往会收紧。你曾经在马里兰大学做过一项研究，通过给人一种过度拥挤或没有过度拥挤的感觉来操纵人们的态度或威胁感。告诉我那个实验以及你发现了什么，米歇尔。
And actually, we've seen in some of our computational models, the same exact logic. As threat increases survival. And actually, we've seen in some of our computational models the same exact logic. As threat increases in our mathematical models, we see that groups tend to evolve to be tighter. So there seems to be something that may make evolutionary sense that under a lot of threat that we tend to tighten up. You once ran a study at the University of Maryland where you manipulated people's attitudes or sense of threat by giving them a sense of overcrowding or a lack of overcrowding. Tell me about that experiment and what you found Misha.
是的，所以我们在这次实验中有两个条件。在一个条件下，人们被告知马里兰大学拥有美国校园中最高或最高的人口密度之一。我们向他们展示了图表，并配有关于在教室里找座位和在工会吃午餐有多么困难的引言。在另一个条件下，我们说了完全相反的话。我们向他们展示了图片，显示马里兰州的人口密度非常低，有时甚至很难看到周围的人。
Yeah, so we basically had two conditions in this experiment. In one condition, people were told that the University of Maryland had the highest or of the highest population density of campuses in the United States. We showed them charts that showed this accompanying with quotes about how hard it was to find a seat in classrooms and to get lunch at the union. And in another condition, we said the exact opposite. We showed them pictures that showed that Maryland was very low population density, and it was really sometimes hard to even see people around.
但我们发现的结果是惊人的，在高人口密度条件下，当我们询问人们对违反规范的行为有多困扰时，我们发现与低人口密度条件相比，当人们违反规范时，他们要心烦意乱得多。这表明，在我们认为有意义的情境中，我们作为人类可以迅速收紧。当我们引发恐怖主义威胁或自然灾害威胁时，我们在其他研究中也能看到这一点。我们在神经科学研究中甚至也能看到这一点。
But what we found was striking, in the high population density condition, when we asked people how bothered they were by norm violations, we found that they were much more upset when people were violating norms as compared to the low population density condition. That suggests that we as humans can quickly tighten up in context where we think it makes sense. And we can see that in other studies when we prime terrorism threats or natural disaster threats. And we even see this in neuroscience studies.
如果威胁是文化紧密性的驱动因素，米歇尔发现民族多样性往往是文化紧密性的驱动因素，米歇尔发现民族多样性往往是文化紧密性的驱动因素。当来自不同背景的人们聚集在一起时，他们必须找到适应彼此的方法，如果你对规则非常死板，那就很难做到这一点。米歇尔对来自30多个国家的约7000人进行了调查。我问她，关于哪些国家是规则遵循者，哪些国家是规则打破者，她发现了什么。在这项研究中，我们发现紧密-松散是一个连续体。
If threat is a driver of cultural tightness, Michelle finds that ethnic diversity is often a driver of cultural tightness, Michelle finds that ethnic diversity is often a driver of cultural looseness. When people from different backgrounds come together, they have to find ways to adapt to one another, and that's tough to do if you're very rigid about the rules. Michelle conducted a survey of some 7,000 people from more than 30 countries. I asked her what she found about which countries were rule followers and which ones were rule breakers. In this study, we found that tight loose was a continuum.
像日本、新加坡、德国和奥地利这样的国家倾向于偏紧。而像新西兰、巴西、荷兰和希腊这样的国家则倾向于偏松。当然，所有国家都有紧密和松散的元素。例如在日本，尽管它相当严格，但也有指定的时间与主管一起玩乐和喝酒。而且，你知道，在其他情境中，比如在我们数据中偏松的新西兰，例如，你会看到人们光着脚在全国各地的银行走来走去，新西兰也有一些相当紧密的领域，当人们试图脱颖而出时，这些领域就会显现出来。他们称他们为高罂粟花。
Countries like Japan, Singapore, Germany, and Austria tend to veer tight. And countries like New Zealand, Brazil, the Netherlands, and Greece tend to veer loose. And of course, all countries have tight and loose elements. In Japan, for example, even though it's pretty strict, there's designated times to kind of have fun and get drunk with your supervisors. And, you know, even in other contexts like New Zealand, which veers loose in our
新西兰是一个高度崇尚平等主义的地方。因此，脱颖而出真的违反了那种强烈的价值观。这就是为什么那是新西兰一个相当紧密的领域。我的理论是，在一个国家中任何真正超级重要的领域都会进化得紧密。所以在新西兰，我们可以看到，当你打破平等主义的规则时，你会得到一些严重的负面反馈，而在许多其他领域，它相当松散。
data, where you see people walking barefoot and banks around the country, for example, there's also domains that are pretty tight in New Zealand that manifest itself when people are trying to stand out. They call them tall poppies. New Zealand is a place that's high on egalitarianism. So standing out is really violating that strong value. And that's why that's a domain that's pretty tight in New Zealand. My theory would be that any domain that's really super important in a country evolves to be tight. And so in New Zealand we can see that when you break the rules of being a egalitarian you can get some serious negative feedback whereas in many other domains it's pretty loose.
所以我想知道你刚才所说的是否实际上解释了为什么如果你看看像巴基斯坦或印度这样在你样本中最紧密的国家，你也可以看到相当数量的规则打破行为。所以，你知道，如果你，如果任何人曾在印度或巴基斯坦开过车，他们不会说这些是下定决心遵守规则的国家。是的，嗯，我认为这是一个很好的例子，每个国家都有可能更紧密或更松散的领域。在巴基斯坦和印度，你可以看到驾驶那种公开的行为，埃及是另一个例子。
So I'm wondering if what you said just now actually explains why if you look at countries like So I'm wondering if what you said just now actually explains why if you look at countries like Pakistan or India which were among the tightest nations in your sample, you can also see a significant amount of rule breaking. So, you know, if you're, if you've anyone's driven a car in India or Pakistan, they would not say that these are countries that are hell bent on following the rules. Yeah, well, I think that that's a really great example that there can be domains that every country has that are tighter loose. In Pakistan and India, you see that kind of public behavior of driving Egypt as another example.
我在埃及度过了很长时间，我在出租车里时只是闭上眼睛，祈求最好的结果。但在其他领域，在性别、权力和宗教方面，它们进化得非常紧密。所以使用显微镜并放大，试图理解在任何国家、任何情境下哪些领域是紧密的，哪些领域是松散的，这真的很重要。米歇尔还分析了美国不同州如何表现出对规则的强烈遵循与微弱遵循。
I've spent a lot of time in Egypt, and I just close my eyes when I'm in a taxi, just hope for the best. But in other domains, in terms of gender and authority and religion, they evolved to be very tight. So it's really important to kind of take that microscope and then zoom in and try to understand in any country, in any context what domains are tight and what domains are loose. Michelle has also analyzed how different states within the US demonstrate strong rule following versus weak rule following.
是的，嗯，我真的很想看看，你知道，超越红与蓝，这种表面类型的分类，以了解我们是否能看到全国各地在紧密和松散方面的差异，它是否遵循与国家层面差异相同的逻辑？这正是我们所展示的。我们可以对美国各州进行排名，看到南部和国家层面差异的地方。这正是我们所展示的。我们可以对美国各州进行排名，看到南部以及中西部的一些地方（如堪萨斯州）倾向于偏紧，而海岸边的地方（如纽约、
Yeah, well, I was really interested to see, you know, move beyond red versus blue, this kind of superficial type of taxonomy to understand whether we could see differences in tightness and looseness around the country and does it follow the same logic as differences at the national level? And that's exactly what we showed. We can rank order the US states and see that places in the south and as differences at the national level. And that's exactly what we showed. We can rank order the US states and see that places in the south and in some part the Midwest, like Kansas, tend to veer tight and places on the coast, like New York
马萨诸塞州和加利福尼亚州）倾向于偏松。这真的很有趣，因为我们发现国家层面的一些相同预测因素也解释了州层面的紧密-松散差异。紧密州在历史上往往有更多的自然灾害，它们也有更高的病原体流行率和粮食不安全感。在松散州，我们的数据中有更多样性。当你看着你列在光谱上的那些州时，我看了看数据，看起来密西西比州、阿拉巴马州、阿肯色州、俄克拉荷马州、田纳西州、德克萨斯州、路易斯安那州、肯塔基州、南卡罗来纳州和北卡罗来纳州是10个最紧密的州。
and Massachusetts and California tend to veer looser. It was really interesting because what we found was that some of the same predictors at the national level also explain tightness loosens differences at the state level. Tight states tended to have more natural disasters across their histories and they also had more pathogen prevalence and food insecurity. In loose dates, it had more diversity in our data. When you look at the states that you put on the spectrum, and I looked at the data, it looks like Mississippi, Alabama, Arkansas, Oklahoma, Tennessee, Texas, Louisiana, Kentucky, South Carolina, and North Carolina are the 10 tightest states.
而你样本中较松散的州是加利福尼亚州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州、内华达州、缅因州、马萨诸塞州、康涅狄格州、夏威夷州、新罕布什尔州、佛蒙特州、内华达州、缅因州、马萨诸塞州、康涅狄格州、夏威夷州、新罕布什尔州、佛蒙特州和阿拉斯加州。现在，前10个最紧密的州中的每一个在总统选举中都是可靠的共和党人，而10个较松散的州中有9个是可靠的民主党人。那么紧密和松散与保守和自由之间有什么联系，它们实际上是彼此的代名词吗？
And the loser states in your sample were California, Oregon, Washington, Nevada, Maine, Massachusetts, Connecticut, Hawaii, New Hampshire, Vermont, Nevada, Maine, Massachusetts, Connecticut, Hawaii, New Hampshire, Vermont, and Alaska. Now, every one of the top 10 tightest states is reliably Republican in presidential elections, and nine out of the 10 loser states is reliably democratic. So what's the connection between tight and lose and conservative and liberal and are they actually proxies for one another?
是的，它们确实相关，但它们是不同的。你可以把个人层面的共和党民主党偏好想成是这样，而紧密和松散实际上更多是在社会社区层面，但它们确实相互加强。所以当人们真正拥有紧密的心态（我们建议这在总体上更多存在于共和党人中，
Yeah, they're really related, but they're distinct. You can think about Republican Democrat preferences at the individual level, and tightness and lose is really more at the social community level, but they really reinforce each other. So when people really have tight mindsets, which we suggest is more among Republicans in general,
并非在所有领域），那么他们往往会创造出有很多规则的情境。同样，自由主义者实际上可能在包容度更高的情境中更快乐。所以它们彼此相互加强。但你也可以设想生活在紧密和松散环境中的共和党人或民主党人，这些环境与他们的取向不匹配。可以肯定的是，这些定义中还有细微差别的空间。
not in all domains, then they tend to create contexts that have a lot of rules. And likewise, liberals might actually be happier in context where there is more permissiveness. So they kind of mutually reinforce each other. But you can also envision people who are Republican or Democrat living in tight and loose environments that are mismatched with their orientation as well. To be sure, there is room for nuance in these definitions.
例如，一些红州可能更喜欢紧密的文化附加物，但在法规方面却主张更松散的方法。相比之下，像加利福尼亚州这样一个文化上松散的州，在工作场所或环境法规方面可能更紧密。但紧密-松散框架为我们提供了一种思考潜在偏好的方式，这些偏好塑造了我们应对世界的方式。接下来，了解在面对诸如冠状病毒疫情这样的全球大流行时，各国如何协调或未能共同努力。
Some red states, for example, may prefer tight cultural additives, but are for a loser approach when it comes to regulations. By contrast, a culturally loose state like California can be tighter when it comes to workplace or environmental regulations. But the tight loose framework gives us a way of thinking about the underlying preferences that shape the way we respond to the world. Coming up, understanding how nations coordinate or fail to work together when it comes to a global pandemic like the coronavirus outbreak.
冠状病毒大流行正在非常迅速地改变一切。因此，我们创建了一个播客，你可以在其中听到来自NPR记者的对话和故事，他们正在报道大流行、与之作斗争的公共卫生以及世界如何应对。我是你的主持人凯利·麦克埃弗斯，收听并订阅NPR的“冠状病毒每日播客”。米歇尔，鉴于国家之间以及国家内社区之间的巨大我想谈谈当不同的文化态度相互碰撞时会发生什么。1994年，一名美国少年在新加坡被抓到破坏一些汽车。我希望你听一段关于这个故事的新闻片段。没有人知道它会发生什么时候，但在服完四个月监禁刑期中的五周后，这位高中生
The coronavirus pandemic is changing everything really fast. So we have created a podcast where you can hear conversations and stories from NPR journalists who are covering the pandemic, the public health fight against it, and how the world is coping. I'm your host, Kelly McEvers, listen and subscribe to Coronavirus Daily from NPR. Michelle, given the large differences between nations and between communities with the nations, I want to talk about what happens when different cultural attitudes collide with one another. In 1994, an American teenager was caught vandalizing some cars in Singapore. I want you to listen to a news clip about the story. No one knew when it would take place, but after serving five weeks of his four-month prison sentence, high school
冠状病毒大流行正在以极快的速度改变一切。因此，我们制作了一个播客，在这里你可以听到NPR记者的对话和故事，他们正在报道这场大流行病、与之抗争的公共卫生斗争以及世界如何应对。我是主持人凯利·麦克埃弗斯，请收听并订阅NPR的《每日冠状病毒》。米歇尔，鉴于国家之间以及国家内部社区之间存在巨大差异，我想谈谈当不同的文化态度发生碰撞时会发生什么。1994年，一名美国少年在新加坡因涂鸦汽车被抓。我想请你听一段关于这个故事的新闻片段。没有人知道它何时会发生，但在服刑四个月的刑期五周后，这名高中生
student Michael Fay was flogged with a rat-and-cane soaked in antiseptic. Four lashes, not six. The reduced punishment was the result of President Clinton's appeal for clemency to the Singapore government. Tell me what happened, Misha. Yeah, Singapore viewers really tight, and they corner the market on order. They have very little crime. They have a lot of police per capita. And in the U.S. we're much more open.
学生迈克尔·费伊被一根浸过防腐剂的藤条抽打。四鞭，不是六鞭。之所以减轻处罚，是因为克林顿总统曾向新加坡政府呼吁宽大处理。米沙，告诉我发生了什么。是的，新加坡人在秩序方面抓得很紧，他们几乎垄断了秩序。他们的犯罪率很低。他们的人均警察数量很多。而在美国，我们则开放得多。
We have more crime and we have less order. And in this particular case, Michael Fay was caught vandalizing various property in Singapore. And he got the typical punishment, which was a fine and imprisonment, but also he was cained, which was a typical punishment in Singapore. And this set off really a big conflict between the U.S. and Singapore, including even Bill Clinton trying to get involved to get the Singapore government to be more lenient. And they did eventually become a little more lenient, but they were also saying to us, hey, we have our own ideas
我们的犯罪率更高，而秩序更少。在这个特定的案例中，迈克尔·费伊在新加坡因破坏各种财产而被抓获。他受到了典型的惩罚，即罚款和监禁，但他也挨了鞭刑，这是新加坡的一种典型惩罚。这确实引发了美国和新加坡之间的大规模冲突，甚至包括比尔·克林顿试图介入，让新加坡政府更加宽容一些。他们最终确实变得稍微宽容了一些，但他们也在对我们说，嘿，我们有自己的想法
about how to organize our country and don't try to tell us how to be looser, look at your own New York City streets at the time and see how much disorder you have, leave us alone, and let us manage our own country how we like. And this is a good example of differences in emphasis on order and openness really collide at the national level when it comes to how we organize cultural groups. You have an example of cultures colliding in your own life, your native New Yorker, and one time you and your boyfriend were driving on Interstate 95 in South Carolina when a driver cut you off. Tell me the story of what happened next, Michelle.
关于如何组织我们的国家，不要试图告诉我们要如何散漫，看看你们当时自己的纽约市街头，看看你们有多少混乱，请别管我们，让我们按照我们喜欢的方式管理我们自己的国家。当涉及到我们如何组织文化群体时，这是一个很好的例子，展示了对秩序和开放性的强调程度的不同如何在国家层面发生冲突。你在自己的生活中也有文化冲突的例子，你是个土生土长的纽约人，有一次你和你的男朋友开着车行驶在南卡罗来纳州的95号州际公路上，当时有一个司机超车别了你们。米沙，请告诉我接下来发生了什么故事。
Yeah, this was a pretty scary situation in the early 90s. I was driving in South Carolina with my then boyfriend now husband, and I come from New York where, you know, and it's a pretty loose place. And the South tends to be pretty tight. It was founded by people who came from cultures of honor where rules are really important.
是的，这是90年代初一个相当可怕的情况。当时我和我当时的男友、现在的丈夫正开车在南卡罗来纳州行驶，我来自纽约，如你所知，那是一个相当散漫的地方。而南方往往相当严谨。它是由那些来自荣誉文化背景的人建立的，在这种文化中，规则非常重要。
And so there's a lot of things that you need to be attended to in the South in terms of rules. And one of them is not flipping people off on the road, which is really a strong, normal violation. And what happened to us was that we were driving along. And I guess what happened was that this car cut off our car. And so Todd just naturally just flipped him off. And this turned into a pretty dangerous situation, a kind of road rage where we were being
所以在南方，有很多事情需要你在规则方面予以关注。其中之一就是在路上不要向别人竖中指，这真是一个强烈的社会规范违背。发生在我们身上的是，我们正开着车。我猜发生的事情是，这辆车别了我们的车。所以托德很自然地就向对方竖了中指。这变成了一个相当危险的情况，一种路怒症，我们被
followed by this car. We finally figured out a way to get off the road and we sort of took a quick exit, but the car followed us off the road. And I tried to get Todd to apologize to this person and he did and it ended well. But it just suggests that when we're even in our own country, there's different places that have strict rules that we need to abide by, or you're going to get yourself into some serious trouble, and in other contexts, you can be much more loose. So the interesting thing, of course, is that in that moment, you have this, what feels
这辆车跟踪了。我们终于想出了一个离开公路的办法，我们算是一个急下高速，但这辆车跟着我们下了公路。我试图让托德向这个人道歉，他也照做了，结局很好。但这只是表明，当我们甚至在自己的国家时，不同地方会有我们需要遵守的严格规则，否则你会让自己陷入严重的麻烦，而在其他情况下，你可以散漫得多。所以有趣的是，当然，在那一刻，你有了这种感觉
like a cultural altercation, and no one's actually thinking at that point. Well, of course, everyone flips everyone off in New York. It's it's what you do it's it's an act of love i was going to say it's it's it's it's it's that's right of course in the south that's completely that would be complete no no that's right and in fact when i went to shampian or bannett to get my phd i was flipping people off a lot in shampian or banna and and uhbana. And I think people kind of realize, she's really coming from another planet.
像是一场文化冲突，而当时没有人真正在思考。嗯，当然，在纽约每个人都对每个人竖中指。这是你做的事，这是一种爱的行为，我是说，那是……没错，当然在南方这完全是，那将是彻底的禁忌，没错，事实上，当我去了尚佩恩-厄巴纳攻读博士学位时，我在尚佩恩-厄巴纳经常对别人竖中指。我想人们有点意识到，她真的是来自另一个星球。
And after five years there, I really kind of toned it down. But that's right. I think that behavior is seen as really acceptable in the context of New York. We find some pretty interesting also other differences that I report on in the book that the tight states are really very polite, like actually the correlation between tightness scores and politeness scores is pretty strong.
在那儿呆了五年之后，我真的收敛了很多。但这是真的。我认为这种行为在纽约的语境下被认为是完全可以接受的。我们还发现了一些我在书中报道的其他相当有趣的差异，即严谨的州实际上非常礼貌，事实上，严谨程度得分与礼貌程度得分之间的相关性相当强。
And so loose states are seen as pretty rude actually. New York is ranked as the number one rudest state in the union by beloved New York. But loose states in our research are much more fun according to indications of how many recreational activities there are of how many recreational activities there are, how many artists there are per capita. So you can see this kind of tightness trade-off, this what I call the order versus openness trade-off. And it's important to realize that each culture has its strength and it's really important
因此，散漫的州实际上被认为相当粗鲁。根据最受喜爱的纽约网站的排名，纽约被评为联邦中第一粗鲁的州。但在我们的研究中，根据有多少娱乐活动、人均有多少艺术家的指标显示，散漫的州要有趣得多。所以你可以看到这种严谨性的权衡，我称之为秩序与开放性的权衡。认识到每种文化都有其优势这一点很重要，而且非常重要
to recognize and see that they both really have strengths and liabilities. Can you talk about the strengths of each for a moment? When you look at tight cultures, you mentioned a second ago that they rule followers, they're very polite, but you also find correlations with things like conscientiousness and how much people help on another. So talk a little bit about the strengths of tight cultures,
去认识并看到它们两者确实都各有利弊。你能花一点时间谈谈各自的优势吗？当你审视严谨的文化时，你刚才提到它们是规则的遵循者，它们非常礼貌，但你也会发现它们与责任心以及人们互相帮助的程度等因素存在相关性。所以请谈谈严谨文化的优势，
and then we'll talk in a second about the strengths of loose cultures. Sure. I think that tight cultures corner the market on order. So they have less crime, they have more law enforcement per capita, and they're much more synchronized. So we find that people are more likely to dress the same and drive more similar cars. Even financial markets, researchers showing are more synchronized in tight cultures in terms
然后我们稍后再谈谈散漫文化的优势。当然。我认为严谨的文化垄断了秩序。所以它们的犯罪率更低，人均执法力度更大，并且它们的一致性高得多。因此我们发现人们更有可能穿着相同的服装，开更相似的汽车。研究人员甚至表明，在买卖股票方面，严谨文化中的金融市场一致性更高。严谨文化的另一个优势是它们有更多的自我控制。因此，当你处于一个有大量社会控制的环境中时，人们从小就被教导如何管理自己的冲动。这意味着他们自我调节能力更强。在许多不同类型的领域，就他们的饮食而言。我们发现严谨文化的肥胖率较低，债务较低，酗酒率也较低。事实上，在为这本书做研究时，我发现即使是宠物在严谨文化中往往也更瘦。我对此深有体会，因为我的狗佩珀
of buying and selling stocks. And another advantage of tight cultures is that they have more self-control. So when you're in your context where there's a lot of social control, people are taught from a very early age to manage their impulses. And so that means that they're more self-regulated. And many different types of domains, in terms of how much they eat. We find that tight cultures have lower obesity, they have lower debt, and they also have lower alcoholism. Actually, in research for the book, I found that even pets tend to be skinnier in tight cultures. And I can relate to that because my dog, Pepper,
体型挺大的。我在马里兰州的同事和我总是笑，我的德国合作者总是笑着说，德国狗比美国狗瘦得多。但这恰恰提出了一个重要观点：严谨文化垄断了秩序，而散漫文化则在秩序方面苦苦挣扎。它们的犯罪率更高，一致性更低，并有一系列自我调节问题。但正如你所提到的，它们也有它们的优势。那么其中一些优势是什么呢？
is pretty big. And my colleague at Maryland, and I always laugh, my German collaborator, always laugh, that he says that German dogs are much skinnier than American dogs. But this just raises an important point that tight cultures corner the market on order and loose culture struggle with order. They have more crime, they're less synchronized, and they have a host of self-regulation problems. But as you mentioned, they also have their strengths. And so what are some of those strengths?
我是说，你刚才谈到了创造力和人均更多的艺术家数量。但请具体谈谈。在那些拥有这些散漫规范的地方，究竟发生了什么能让他们真正取得成功？是的，所以当人们在不同文化中看到那些因看起来不同而被污名化的人时，我对他们的反应非常感兴趣。
I mean, you talk to a second about creativity and a greater per capita number of artists. But just talk about it. What happens in places that have these loser norms that allows them to really succeed? Yeah, so I was really interested in how people react to people who were stigmatized who look different in different cultures.
所以我做了这样一个研究：我训练了来自不同文化的志愿者回到他们的国家。我给他们买了一些假的面部疣。你可以在网上买到。非常简单。在一种情况下，他们的脸上戴着假的面部疣。而在另一种情况下，他们纹身、戴着鼻环和顶着紫色的头发。然后在另一种情况下，他们只是露出
And so I did this study where I trained people from different cultures to go back to their countries. And I bought them fake facial wards. You can buy them on the internet. Pretty easy. And in one condition, they were wearing fake facial wards on their faces. And then another condition, they were wearing tattoos and nose rings and purple hair. And then another condition they were just wearing
他们原本的脸。我做了一个简单的实验，让他们去世界各地，在城市街道上请求帮助，或者在商店里请求帮助。有趣的是，当人们露出他们本来的面孔时，并没有什么区别。无论人们在世界各地是指路还是在商店里提供帮助，人们是否愿意帮助他们都是一样的。但当他们戴着这些古怪的面部
their plain face. And I had a simple experiment where we had them go around the world and ask for help on city streets or ask for help in stores. And what was interesting is that when people were wearing their normal face, there was no difference. And whether people were likely to help them around the world in terms of giving them directions or giving them help in stores. But when they were wearing these weird facial
疣或纹身时，我们发现与严谨文化相比，散漫文化中的人更有可能帮助他们。所以我们可以看到，世界各地的人们对受污名化之人的反应存在巨大差异。这不仅发生在城市街道上，也表现在调查中，以及内隐态度上。因此，散漫文化垄断了开放性。所以如果你看一下仇外心理之类的东西，例如，你在散漫文化中看到的仇外心理可能会远远少于严谨文化。
warts or tattoos, we found that people in loose cultures were much more likely to help them as compared to tight cultures. So we can see that there's a big difference in how people react to the stigmatized around the world. And this is not just in city streets, it's on surveys, it's with implicit attitudes. So loose culture is corner of the market on openness. And so if you look at something like xenophobia, for example, you're likely to see far less xenophobia in a loose culture than in a tight culture.
没错。因此，人们对不同种族、不同宗教的人、移民、残疾人以及许多其他带有污名的人更加开放，而严谨文化则在开放性方面苦苦挣扎。当你审视这些不同态度之间的张力时，米歇尔，这种散漫与严谨的张力，它是如何运作的？
That's right. So people are much more open to people of different races, religions, of immigrants, people with disabilities, and many different other stigmas, and tight cultures struggle with openness. When you look at the tension between these different attitudes, Michelle, the looseness tightness tension, how does this play business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business, and business to see the deep cultural iceberg of tightness and looseness that's really beneath the surface. So think back to a great example of tight-loose conflict, happen in a dimelur Chrysler merger, where these two companies coming from the US Chrysler and dimelur from Germany at first glance, it seemed like a match made in heaven, and a lot of people thought this was going to be a great marriage.
商业，以及在商业中，看到潜藏在水面之下的严谨与散漫的深层文化冰山。所以回想一下严谨与散漫冲突的一个极佳例子，它发生在戴姆勒-克莱斯勒合并案中，这两家公司分别来自美国的克莱斯勒和来自德国的戴姆勒，乍一看，这似乎是一场天作之合，许多人认为这将是一桩伟大的婚姻。
But in fact, their cultural differences in tightness and looseness seemed to really rear their ugly head, such that sometime after they're merged, we see that they actually experience a larger cultural conflict and they divorced, as people would say. And it makes sense that people, the practices, and the leadership is profoundly different in tight and loose organizations. And when they come to collide, we see that it actually could be very costly.
但事实上，他们在严谨和散漫方面的文化差异似乎真的露出了丑陋的面目，以至于在他们合并一段时间后，我们发现他们实际上经历了更大的文化冲突，正如人们所说，他们离婚了。人们的做法、实践和领导力在严谨和散漫的组织中有着深刻的不同，这是合乎情理的。当它们发生碰撞时，我们看到它实际上代价高昂。
In a recent study, we actually studied thousands of cross-border acquisitions. And we could see that differences in tightness and looseness between them was costly, even as much as $250 million when you see big differences in tight loose. And I imagine the same thing also happens within organizations that are not merging with other organizations. You know, you're hiring someone from New York and you're hiring someone from Kansas. They're working next to one another and they have potentially different attitudes. Yeah, that's exactly right.
在最近的一项研究中，我们实际研究了数千起跨境并购。我们可以看到，它们之间在严谨和散漫上的差异是代价高昂的，当严谨与散漫存在巨大差异时，代价甚至高达2.5亿美元。我猜同样的事情也会发生在那些没有与其他组织合并的组织内部。你知道，你从纽约雇一个人，又从堪萨斯雇一个人。他们并肩工作，可能持有不同的态度。是的，完全正确。
And in fact, a lot of organizations, within organizations, there's lots of differences in tightness and looseness. Think about sales versus an R&D versus accounting. It makes sense that these groups would veer differently on tightness and looseness. And in fact, the people who are attracted to those kinds of jobs likely have tightness mindsets that really
事实上，在许多组织内部，严谨与散漫之间存在着很多差异。想想销售部门与研发部门再到会计部门。这些群体在严谨和散漫上的倾向有所不同，这是合乎情理的。事实上，那些被这类工作吸引的人可能拥有严谨的心态，这确实
cause a lot of conflict when they interact with each other. Sometimes organizations who want to loosen up, for example, I interviewed people in manufacturing firms who said, hey, we want to become more innovative. We're going to hire groups to help us do that that are much looser, but what we found was that they actually had so much cultural conflict. When you're used to a lot of order and efficiency and then you hire a group that's much more creative and may miss some deadlines, this causes a lot of cultural conflict. And so I think if we can think about tightness and looseness as it relates to mergers, we can anticipate this conflict better and negotiate them ahead of time.
在他们相互交往时引发了大量的冲突。有时，想要变得更散漫的组织，例如，我采访过制造公司的员工，他们说，嘿，我们要变得更有创新精神。我们要聘请团队来帮助我们做到这一点，他们要散漫得多，但我们发现他们实际上有这么多的文化冲突。当你习惯了大量的秩序和效率，然后你雇佣了一个更具创造性、可能会错过一些截止日期的团队时，这会引起大量的文化冲突。因此，我认为如果我们能够将严谨和散漫与并购联系起来考虑，我们就能更好地预见这种冲突，并提前进行谈判。
How do you prevent this work from becoming a form of essentialism, if you will? You basically say, all right, now I'm seeing that there's a risk when you have a German company emerging with an American company. So I'm oversimplifying these findings and say, okay, all American companies should never look to German companies to borrow money from. Or you should never put a New Yorker in the same room as someone from Kansas. Then you have some of the problems that you have with personality tests, where you have basically these general tendencies amplified to a point where people are taking them
你如何防止这项工作变成一种本质主义的形式？你基本上会说，好吧，现在我看到当一家德国公司与一家美国公司合并时存在风险。所以我过度简化了这些发现，并说，好吧，所有美国公司永远都不应该找德国公司借钱。或者你绝不应该把一个纽约人和一个堪萨斯人关在同一个房间里。这样一来，你就会遇到一些与性格测试相同的问题，即你基本上将这些普遍倾向放大到了人们对待它们的程度
perhaps a little too serious. Yeah, I think this is a really important point because this construct, we can apply it across different levels and certain occupations and certain industries in the US via tighter the military, airlines, nuclear power plants, hospitals, they need stronger rules, other occupations and industries are much looser. So even in the US we don't have one organizational culture clearly. And again at the individual level we all mean tighter loose for good reasons but there's certain domains that we might be tighter or looser in. So the more important point is to diagnose the levels of tight and loose
也许有点太严肃了。是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题，因为这个概念，我们可以把它应用到不同的层面，在美国的某些职业和某些行业会更加严谨：军队、航空公司、核电站、医院，它们需要更强有力的规则，而其他职业和行业则要散漫得多。因此，即使在美国，我们也没有一个明确的单一组织文化。同样在个人层面，我们出于充分的理由意味着严谨或散漫，但在某些领域我们可能会更严谨或更散漫。所以更重要的一点是诊断严谨和散漫的水平
in context where we're merging and figure out where our strengths are and where our liabilities are and talk about them, have cultural conversations, have conversations about culture, negotiate culture ahead of time. But the important thing is to really understand that culture is driving a lot of the conflict in the first place. So when you look at the US as a whole, you also find that the degree of tightness within the US has changed over time. Talk about that.
在我们正在合并的语境中，弄清楚我们的优势和劣势在哪里，并讨论它们，进行文化对话，就文化进行对话，提前协商文化。但最重要的是要真正理解文化首先是许多冲突的根源。因此，当你把美国作为一个整体来看时，你也会发现美国内部的严谨程度随着时间的推移发生了变化。谈谈这个。
How is it changed in what direction and what are the drivers? Yeah, it's a great question. What we found with striking is that over the last 200 years, we've become much looser. What we can see is that it's associated with this exact order and openness trade-off I was mentioning. So, looseness has really caused much more creativity, patents,
它是如何变化的，朝着什么方向变化的，驱动因素是什么？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们发现惊人的是，在过去的200年里，我们变得更加散漫了。我们可以看到，它与我刚才提到的这种确切的秩序与开放性的权衡有关。因此，散漫确实带来了更多的创造力、专利、
trademarks, and so forth, but it's also produced less order, more debt, for example. And so we can see that the US has changed, has become more loose, and it has the same associated trade-offs. Of course, we can also see that during times of threat, we tend to tighten up. And so we can also see this as a dynamic construct that it's not as though the world's becoming looser. When we have collective threats, we can also see shifts to tightness. So when you're speaking about collective threats, it makes me think of course of the coronavirus outbreak
商标等等，但它也带来了较少的秩序，例如更多的债务。因此我们可以看到，美国已经发生了变化，变得更加散漫，并且它具有相同的相关权衡。当然，我们也可以看到，在受到威胁的时期，我们往往会收紧。因此，我们也可以将这视为一个动态的概念，并不是说世界正在变得越来越散漫。当我们面临集体威胁时，我们也可以看到向严谨的转变。所以当你谈到集体威胁时，我自然想到了冠状病毒疫情
that we are experiencing right now in 2020. And when you look at how different countries in the world are coping with the coronavirus outbreak, do you see the same hand of culture at play? Yeah, I think that it's really important to think about the spread of corona, not just from a medical point of view, but also from a cultural point of view. And we see striking differences around the world in response to corona.
我们目前正经历的2020年。当你审视世界上不同的国家是如何应对冠状病毒疫情时，你是否看到了相同的文化之手在起作用？是的，我认为从医学角度以及文化角度来思考冠状病毒的传播是非常重要的。我们在世界各地看到了应对冠状病毒的惊人差异。
You know, tight societies like Singapore and Hong Kong, for example, have demonstrated a really effective quick swift response. Singapore has had very few deaths. And the United States, the response so far, echoes our loose cultural programming. It's been conflicted, it's been unstandardized, it's been uncoordinated. And I think that, you know, this is a cultural issue,
你知道，像新加坡和香港这样严谨的社会，已经表现出非常有效、迅速的反应。新加坡的死亡人数非常少。而美国迄今为止的反应，呼应了我们散漫的文化程序。它一直充满冲突、没有标准化、没有协调。我认为，这是一个文化问题，
because loose cultures who've had tended to have less threat haven't had the kind of context where they realized the importance of sacrificing liberty and realized the importance of sacrifice and liberty and autonomy and freedom for constraint and rules. And we have kind of an ambivalence about tightness in the United States and in general. And here's where we see that this is a real liability that we do see in our data analyses that loose cultures have had higher spread of the disease, different trajectories
因为那些倾向于面临较少威胁的散漫文化，并没有那种意识到牺牲自由的重要性、意识到为约束和规则而牺牲自由、自主权和独立性的重要性的环境。我们在美国以及总体上对严谨有一种矛盾心理。正是在这里，我们看到这是一个真正的劣势，我们在数据分析中确实看到，散漫文化比严谨文化经历了更高程度的疾病传播、
than tighter cultures. And that's not to say that we should give up our creative loose spirit. It just means that we need to tighten up to fight the disease and we need to use our loose spirit to create technologies that can help us to fight it as well. So if you look at countries like Spain and Italy, for example, presumably these are loser cultures, they seem to have very different trajectories of the coronavirus outbreak than countries like South Korea. Yeah, that's right.
不同的轨迹。这并不是说我们应该放弃我们富有创造力的散漫精神。这只是意味着我们需要收紧来对抗疾病，并且我们需要利用我们的散漫精神来创造能够帮助我们对抗疾病的技术。因此，如果你看看像西班牙和意大利这样的国家，假设这些是散漫的文化，与韩国等国家相比，它们似乎有着非常不同的冠状病毒疫情轨迹。是的，没错。
I think that Italy in our research was also a veer of loose and Spain as well. And you could see that, and of course it's multiple determined. It's not just determined by tightness looseness, but it is. You can see that the response in Italy is something that we see here in the US as well, that even people had harder time obeying the rules, even under the quarantines early on, people were trying to leave their communities, which was also causing further spread.
我认为意大利在我们的研究中也是一个散漫的倾向，西班牙也是如此。你可以看到这一点，当然这是由多种因素决定的。它不仅由严谨和散漫决定，但它确实是。你可以看到意大利的反应也是我们在美国这里看到的反应，即使人们在早期即使在隔离期间也很难遵守规则，人们试图离开他们的社区，这也导致了进一步的传播。
And I think that if we think about the meaning of rules, it would help us to tighten up more quickly. So I think if we think about, rules are important to keep us safe, that maybe we'd be more menable to social distancing and handwashing. But we really do need to change our cultural programming in this context. The problem is that it's hard for us to give up liberty for constraint, but it's critical for our safety. So the interesting thing of course is that because most of us don't think about these underlying
我想如果我们思考规则的含义，将有助于我们更快地收紧。所以我认为如果我们思考，规则对于保证我们的安全很重要，也许我们就会更容易接受保持社交距离和洗手。但在这种语境下，我们确实需要改变我们的文化程序。问题在于，我们很难为了约束而放弃自由，但这对于我们的安全至关重要。因此，有趣的是，当然，因为我们大多数人都不会去思考这些潜在的
systems that drive whether we are rule followers or rule breakers, we just assume that the way we are is the way the world ought to be, it becomes quite difficult when you have a situation that suddenly calls for you to exercise a completely different system, right? So if you are part of a tight culture and you're hearing an authoritarian government tell you, everyone stays put and everyone follows the rules, really easy for you to do. But if you come from a loose culture
驱动我们是遵守规则还是打破规则的系统，我们只是认为我们的现状就是世界本该有的样子，当遇到突然需要你执行一个完全不同系统的局限时，这就变得相当困难了，对吧？因此，如果你是严谨文化的一部分，并且你听到一个威权政府告诉你，每个人都待在原地，每个人都遵守规则，这对你来说非常容易做到。但如果你来自一个散漫文化
and you suddenly have a government play the heavy and basically say everyone stays home, business is shut down, there's a part of you that sort of says, hang on, why should I do that? And I think the point that I'm trying to make is that it's one thing to say that we should judiciously decide when to be tight and when to be loose. But I think the paradox here is that because we're not even aware of being tight or lose, we just assume the way we are is the way we ought to be, it's very difficult to change on a dime
而你突然让一个政府扮演强势角色，基本上说每个人都呆在家，企业停业，你心里会有一种声音说，等等，我为什么要那样做？我想表达的观点是，一方面我们要明智地决定何时该严谨，何时该散漫。但这里的悖论在于，由于我们甚至没有意识到自己是严谨还是散漫，我们只是认为我们的现状就是它本该有的样子，当周围的环境发生变化时，要想瞬间改变是非常困难的。
when the situation around us changes. Yeah, I think that's precisely right. And I think these are cultural matters of life and death in my point of view. I think that if we think about this as a temporary shift, that in context of threat, we know from research that we need strong rules to coordinate to survive. You can see this approach in China. They tightened up very quickly in a massive way. They had clearly huge quarantines. They were citizens very quickly in a massive way. They had clearly huge
是的，我认为这完全正确。我认为从我的观点来看，这些都是生死攸关的文化问题。我认为，如果我们认为这是一个暂时的转变，在面临威胁的情境下，我们从研究中得知我们需要强有力的规则来协调以求生存。你可以在中国看到这种方法。他们以极大的规模非常迅速地收紧。他们显然进行了大规模的隔离。他们让公民以极大的规模迅速行动。他们显然进行了大规模的
quarantines. They were citizens were on watch for people that might be showing symptoms. They had temperature, their mom and her is checking people's temperature, people knocking on people's door to check this all in the spirit of trying to control the disease. As it's gotten controlled, there's obviously much less restriction now in Wuhan in other areas. So we can think about this as temporarily tightening up to flatten the curve. And I think that we need strong leadership to tell us that this is the appropriate response in this situation and research suggests that that's the case. So I understand that people always ask you which is better, tight or lose.
隔离。他们的公民都在密切关注可能表现出症状的人。他们测量体温，他们的妈妈和她正在给人们测量体温，人们敲门检查这一切都是为了控制疾病的精神。随着疫情得到控制，武汉和其他地区的限制现在明显少多了。因此，我们可以将其视为为了拉平曲线而进行的暂时收紧。我认为我们需要强有力的领导来告诉我们这是这种情况下适当的反应，研究表明确实如此。所以我明白人们总是问你哪个更好，严谨还是散漫。
What do you tell them, Isha? You know, this is something that we've been thinking about. Philosophers have been talking about for centuries. You know, have people like Plato and Confucius and Hobbes say, no, we need tightness. We need constraint. Hobbes in a particular, we have a pretty negative view of human nature. And then you have people like John Stuart Mill and Freud and particular thought rules make you neurotic.
米沙，你是怎么告诉他们的？你知道，这是我们一直在思考的问题。哲学家们已经讨论了几个世纪。你知道，柏拉图、孔子和霍布斯这样的人说，不，我们需要严谨。我们需要约束。尤其是霍布斯，我们对人性的看法相当消极。然后你又有像约翰·斯图亚特·密尔和弗洛伊德这样的人，他们特别认为规则会让你神经质。
And so what's the answer? Is it tight or loose? I had the hunch that maybe it's neither. Groups clearly need to veer tight or loose for good reasons based on their degree of threat. But what I found is that the groups that get too extreme in either direction, early are dysfunctional. So extreme tightness or extreme looseness produces higher suicide and less happiness. And this is what I call the Goldilocks principle of tight
那么答案是什么呢？是严谨还是散漫？我有这样一种直觉，也许两者都不是。根据威胁程度，群体显然需要出于充分的理由倾向于严谨或散漫。但我发现，在任何一个方向上变得过于极端的群体，往往都是功能失调的。因此，极端的严谨或极端的散漫会导致更高的自杀率和更低的幸福感。这就是我所说的严谨与散漫的
loose. That we need some kind of cultural balance. Really, I think we need to be ambidextrous like using the right and the left hand when it comes to tight loose. And we need leadership to help us deploy tightness under the right circumstances and looseness under others. Michelle Gell-Fan is a psychologist at the University of Maryland. She studies how culture shapes organizations, communities, and nations. She's the author of the book, Rulemakers, Rulebreakers, how tight and loose cultures wire our world. Michelle, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Bread. Thanks for having me. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt.
金发姑娘原则。我们需要某种文化平衡。真的，我认为在面对严谨与散漫时，我们需要像使用左右手那样左右开弓。我们需要领导层帮助我们在正确的情境下运用严谨，在其他情境下运用散漫。米歇尔·杰尔凡是马里兰大学的心理学家。她研究文化如何塑造组织、社区和国家。她是《规则制定者，规则打破者：严谨和散漫的文化如何塑造我们的世界》一书的作者。米歇尔，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。本周的节目由托马斯·刘制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。
Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Pathshah, Raina Cohen, Laura Correll, Kat Chuknecht and Lushikwaba. Arun Sang-Heroes this week are the members of Michelle Galfan's family. With our team walking remotely, we are learning to adjust to the new normal of recording guests from their homes. For our interview, which needed two phones, Michelle's husband Todd lent her his phone and their daughters, Jeanette and Hannah, helped create a quiet space. Oh, thanks also to their birds, Bonnie and Clyde and Doug Pepper for keeping their conversations to a minimum. We appreciate all the help. For more hidden brain, you can find us on
托马斯·刘。由塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括帕特·沙、雷娜·科恩、劳拉·科雷尔、卡特·楚克内希特和鲁希·夸巴。本周的无名英雄是米歇尔·杰尔凡家里的成员。随着我们的团队远程办公，我们正在学习适应从他们的家中记录嘉宾的新常态。对于我们需要两部电话的采访，米歇尔的丈夫托德把他的电话借给了她，他们的女儿珍妮特和汉娜帮忙营造了一个安静的空间。哦，还要感谢他们的鸟，邦妮、克莱德和道格·佩珀将他们的叫声保持在最低限度。我们感谢所有的帮助。想要了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在
Facebook and Twitter. If you like today's show please remember to share it with one friend. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. Right now every household on the country is being asked to fill out the US Census. It's the form that helps us determine how voting districts are withdrawn, where to build public schools and hospitals, how to spend federal money. So why are some people afraid to fill it out? We're getting into all that. This week on MPR's Coot Switch Podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
脸书和推特上找到我们。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请记得分享给一位朋友。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共广播电台。目前，该国的每一个家庭都被要求填写美国人口普查。这份表格帮助我们确定如何重新划分投票区，在哪里建设公立学校和医院，以及如何花联邦资金。那么，为什么有些人害怕填写它呢？我们将深入探讨这一切。本周在NPR的《切换开关》播客中。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。